did you know that an MLB player was once
traded for just one dollar in June 2014
the Milwaukee Brewers traded a pitcher
to the Oakland A's for cash
considerations the term cash
considerations is often a euphemism for
a five or six figure number but in this
trade it was only one dollar yes one
dollar the same worth as a Wendy's
Junior Frosty the trade was a no-brainer
for the ace team that was in need of
immediate help they lost their starting
pitcher Drew pomeranz to the injured
list and another rotation option only
cost them a buck so why did the Brewers
agree to this well unfortunately in the
player's minor league contract Milwaukee
wasn't allowed to receive any
compensation if another team decided to
roster him however the biggest winner
was Brad Mills who went from pitching in
the miners to potentially receiving a
roster spot in the majors Mills did put
up decent numbers for the A's later
earning him a new contract in what was
once a one dollar transaction for a
minor league player turned into a
million dollar opportunity